you've already seen most of the
components of object detection in this
video let's put all the components
together to form the Yolo object
detection algorithm first let's see how
you construct your training set suppose
you're trying to train an algorithm to
detect three objects pedestrians cars
and motorcycles and you will need to
explicitly have the full background
class so just v-class labels here if
you're using to anchor boxes then the
outputs Y will be 3 by 3 because you're
using a three by three prints l by 2
this is the number of anchors by 8
because that's the dimension of this 8
is actually 5 which is and then plus the
number of classes so 5 because you have
PC and in the bounding boxes that's 5
and then C 1 C 2 C 3 that dimension is
equal to the number of classes and you
can either view this as 3 by 3 by 2 by 8
or 3 by 3 by 16 so to construct the
training set you go through each of
these 9 grid cells and form the
appropriate target vector Y so take this
first print cell there's nothing worth
detecting in that grid cell none of the
three causes pedestrian car motorcycle
appear in the upper left grid cell and
so the target y corresponding to that
grid cell will be equal to this where PC
for the first anchor box is 0 because
there's nothing associated the first
hanger box and is also 0 for the second
actor box and so all of these are the
values are don't cares now most of the
grid cells have nothing in them but for
that box over there you would have this
target vector Y so assuming that your
training set has a bounding box like
this for the car it's just a little bit
wider than it is tall and so if your
anchor boxes are that this is a good box
1 this is anchor box 2 then the red box
has just slightly higher iou with anchor
box 2
so the car gets associated with this
lower portion of the vector so notice
then that PC associative Xbox one is
zero so you have don't care as for all
of these components then you have this
PC is equal to one then you should use
these to specify the position of the red
bounding box and then specify that the
correct object is crossed to right that
it is a car so you go through this and
for each of your nine grid positions for
each of your three by three grid
positions you will come up with a vector
like this come up with a 16 dimensional
vector and so that's why the final
output volume is going to be 3 by 3 by
16 oh and as usual for simplicity on
this slide I've used a three by three
grid in practice it might be more like a
19 by 19 by 16 or in fact if you used
more anchor boxes maybe 19 by 19 by 5
times 8 is 5 times 8 is 40 so being 19
by 19 by 40 that's if you use 5 anchor
boxes so that's training and you train a
confident that inputs an image maybe 100
by 100 by 3 and your confident would
then finally output this output volume
in our example 3 by 3 by 16 or 3 by 3 by
2 by 8 next let's look at how your
algorithm can make predictions given an
image your neural network will output
this 3 by 3 by 2 by 8 volume where for
each of the nine current cells you get a
vector like that so for the grid cell
here on the upper left if there's no
object there hopefully your neural
network or I'll put 0 here and 0 here
and then I'll put some of the values
your new network and I'll put a question
mark an output it don't care so I'll put
some numbers for the rest but these
numbers will basically ignore because
the neural network is telling you that
there's no object there so it doesn't
really matter whether it outputs is a
bound the involved Sosuke also basically
be just be
some said the numbers are more less
noise in contrast for this box over here
hopefully the value of y2 the output for
that box at the bottom left hopefully
would be something like 0 4 bounding box
1 and then you know just up with a bunch
of numbers just noise hopefully your
also output a certain numbers that
corresponds to specifying a pretty
accurate bounding box for the car so
that's how the neural network will make
predictions finally you would run this
through non max suppression so just to
make it interesting let's look at a new
test set image here's how you run nan
next suppression if you're using to
anchor boxes then for each of the nine
grid cells you get two predicted
bounding boxes some of them will have
very low probability very low PC but you
still get two predicted bounding boxes
for each of the nine treated cells so
let's say those are the bounding boxes
you get and notice that some of the
bounding boxes can go outside the height
and width of the grid cell then it came
from NYX you then get rid of the low
probability predictions so get rid of
the ones that even a neural network says
gee this object probably is in there so
you get rid of those and then finally if
you have three classes you're trying to
detect trying to detect pedestrians cars
and motorcycles what you do is for each
of the three classes independently run
non-mac suppression for the objects that
were predicted to come from that class
but use non-mac suppression for that for
predictions of the pedestrian the class
for a non-expert suppression for the car
cross and run on Mac suppression for the
motorcycle cause but run that University
three times to generate the final
predictions and so the output of this is
hopefully that you will have detected
all the cause and all the pedestrians in
this image so that's it for the yellow
object detection algorithm which is
really one of the most effective object
detection algorithms that also
encompasses many of the best ideas
across the entire computer vision
literature that remain
to object detection and you get a chance
to practice implementing many components
of this yourself in this week's program
exercise so I hope you enjoy this week's
from exercise there's also an optional
video that follows this one which you
can either watch or not watch as you
please but either way I also look
forward to seeing you next week